yeah beeps now he doesn't use [ __ ]
words this guy is just this is unrolling
stone Konya takes to beeping at his
friends calling words the lowest forms
of communication it's amazing how much I
think
well of course crazy but I also respect
it and I got to start doing that I got
to just look at Bryan Callen and be like
pee pee beep beep beep beep beep beep he
says for the time being Kanye West seems
done with man-made construct constructs
like time-space money and most likely
the detriment of those around him the
human language to the detriment of
universe he says I think words are one
of our most one of our lowest forms of
communication huh that's how I
communicate am i dumb just you know take
out the trash is way better than people
people being going on going on what
sorry take out the trash you don't know
my language left yet also you're still
communicating it's still saying [ __ ] you
just saying beep music sound food
dancing are nonverbal forms of
communication we get so wrapped up into
words
we got to make things that are
speechless we have to make things that
leave people speechless we have to make
things to the level where no one can say
anything that puts me out of a job wow
dude ladies and gentlemen Chris D'Elia
people people on paper I was literally
talking about this on my [ __ ] special
no pain about how if you're so offended
you just become somebody who just makes
sounds to not offend people people
boiling yoga I go like that this is what
Kanye West is literally doing also he's
a rapper dude
how you gonna rap by beeping up you know
who's [ __ ] you know who's really into
this
that means take out the trash dude this
is how scab man tells his wife he wants
to make and she goes okay huh
God people who scat are [ __ ] terrible
scatting doesn't that mean [ __ ] on
someone's chest too or am i away no
Chris it doesn't oops thought it did how
to scatter all these guys gotta be Oh No
and of course he's a wide and his hairs
medium oh dude the guy [ __ ] for show
this is on dude
I didn't want to talk about this this
was something that popped up dude oh I
can't wait to play this hold on this guy
starts off just weed out you gotta have
the most confidence to scat that's for
sure body back I'm Ben Jones I'm a
singer in a musician and in this video
I'm gonna be teaching you a little bit
about how to scout scatting is the use
of your voice as an instrument dude
that's how it goes and then goes like
this
goodnight you've learned goodnight
that's the video you've learned scatting
is the way to use your voice as an
instrument
good night that's all for now that's all
you need to know about scatting and what
you do you create nonsense syllables
sounds nonsense syllables and lives half
words too kind of oh they go black and
white in the middle of him singing in
the middle of him talking they go black
and white over the [ __ ] over what
he's saying and he's going quietly and
these [ __ ] improvise what's good
let's go to a music
scout developed kind of in the third
shouldn't of other members of the band
Scout develop not really some would use
man of soft Nooyi lala-lulu some would
use more dude anybody who does this is
not fit I guarantee you there's no fit
guy that's cats as a matter of fact you
don't have to be fat but you don't work
out and you're skinny fat for real any
guy who's scats would lose would lose a
fight here's the deal if the whole world
fought to the death no weapons everybody
who's scats dies first just straight-up
people come in the leader leader leader
leader leader leader leader leader
leader rude oh choked out dude
so bad I don't know just don't scat you
know